the president is on his way home right
now without a trade deal he says he
decided to delay negotiations until
later this summer over four days mr.
Trump met with Japan's new emperor and
US troops Ben Tracy is in Tokyo man what
did the president accomplish on this
trip
well of course Japan is one of America's
closest allies and President Trump did
really seem to cement his relationship
with Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe
a but overall this trip did seem to be
more ceremony than substance the two
main things that these leaders talked
about were trade and North Korea as
president I have no higher honor than
serving as your commander-in-chief
before leaving Japan president Trump
spoke to about 1,000 sailors on the USS
Wasp part of the massive u.s. 7th fleet
that patrols the Pacific and would be on
the frontlines of any conflict with
North Korea you defend your homeland and
our allies against missile attack with
our most advanced radar and weapon
systems in the world the president also
visited a Japanese warship being
retrofitted to carry american-made
fighter jets military hardware he has
pressured Japan to buy Japan recently
announced its intent to purchase 105
brand new stealth f-35 fighter aircraft
the best in the world during their
weekend summit President Trump in
Japanese Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a did
not reach an overall trade agreement and
at a news conference Sunday they openly
disagreed about North Korea's recent
short-range missile launches which are a
threat to Japan and u.s. servicemembers
stationed here it doesn't matter all I
know is that there have been no nuclear
tests there have been no ballistic
missiles going out
with a highly choreographed state visit
that put president Trump front and
center
Prime Minister Ave still seemed to get
what he wanted
affirmation of the two countries bombed
the us-japan alliance has never been
stronger now president Trump will be
back here in Japan next month for the
g20 summit at that summit he will see
President Xi Jinping of China for the
first time since trade talks broke down
gale all right thank you very much event
Tracie reporting from Tokyo